Swamp Thing is finally slithered its way
into injustice too and the guys over at
nether room recently showed up the
characters Musa and combos make sure to
subscribe to GameSpot's youtube channel
for all delays in justice coverage so
here here's Swamp Thing floppy ears
swampy here he's walking some really
cool stuff about Swamp Thing just from
the visuals that I think are I love the
arts our team who just a little tiny
things like when he jumps any lands a
little harder to see on this stage cuz
it's grassy yeah little splashes what do
you lay out this week goes in the ground
yep accessible bit every duck that's
amazing
under under dry never new housing and a
fighting game could get me hot alright I
was excited that our trailer there's a
shock you just grouses yeah yeah so you
have a plodding methodical walk but
definitely to meet sort of planting
stuff now I'll give you some puns today
by really rare you so many talking about
Swamp rings yeah I want to branch out
type of thing I'm sure we're going to
dig a few up here and there we don't
want to get bogged down in the comedy
yeah I know exactly because what it's
not good at that you know just it's
gonna make things money so here we go
so we'll talk first of all straight up
let's talk about his just normal attacks
which normal attacks do you find to be
kind of his really good of bread and
butter no sure so one thing he has a
super long range sweep I think may be
the longest in the game right now yeah
I'm sure it has to hit yeah to hit so
was back from from distances one
generally but if I get up here to do it
and that can break armor he could
special cancel into it yeah and yeah it
was going to say yeah you can cancel
into it you can go yet it was low
starter
unlike other some of the other caregiver
game right so so we have that that's a
really good sweet very different for
swamped exam what else he's got his his
back to is really important now again
when we say back to we're talking about
the video as many became ego buttons of
light functions one mediums to heart
attack is three character power it's
four so one
three four yep yeah so generally you
know that's one thing that we're going
to talk about booze that way it might
help you to learn that that notation off
and go online to look up combos
that's how they're written yeah exactly
so you says back to yeah it's a forward
progressing big which are very important
I would punch with it a lot yes yeah
yeah and it's got a pretty good start up
but it has a lot of options on yeah
we'll show those so you can do a single
shot there that yeah and now when you
can cancel the left hit yep and then we
have the buddy as your other option all
right low option so yeah which you can
also cancel it through yeah various
stages and is very important Thomas
right exactly and it's cool thing about
this holds good with corner speed the
cool things that when you're making it
exactly when you're doing this one this
so from full screen like when you're in
the middle screen this this year does
not have a lot of trouble there are some
things you can do there goodness yeah
now in the corner that changed yeah it
stands alone so you can do you can
continue on into green sub which will
get to the moment this is a couple moves
that like kind of give him more Diana
support and that's those the corner is
going to be reoccurring swapping yeah
that's that's definitely something that
you went with this is very very powerful
more more but which is the staple and
grappler yep yeah yeah he kind of want
to walk him what to walk you down recipe
so also so that's a great one but you
can also one of my favorites that I use
a lot is the forward to degree yeah this
is probably one of the most popular
moves that I think interesting ability
yeah very long range move always been
use
and it has a couple options yeah so I
think the one we showed a lot is butyl
lithium yeah yeah which came a quarter
like we were talking about more corner
option you can continue it on yeah you
can actually combo without meter in the
corner right but he also has a low
attack which okay we showed him
yeah so you're the high low fixable sets
not the fastest in the world but that's
really incredibly useful when you start
getting to talk about it they make those
things that let him switch size really
important for you know what I mean
playing talking a lot I never Bob up
yeah you really think about is how
you're switching sides I never thought
of it and that is a condom well I get so
it's not meant to be a really powerful
50/50 mix up that's just kind of a nice
tool to use if they're always going over
there till I do this a lot right well
now I did yes great yeah cool
what else we have you like from the we
use a lot o is burning three standing
three is great yes yes covers a lot of
space is active for a little bit longer
than those of our half and again that's
multiple hits as well for a blow when we
talk about like space control yeah this
right here is swamp things oh yeah I own
this yeah also his jump three what kind
of a lot of range and up tree jump is
actually called jump truck period get up
free jump tree yeah one day of the moves
I love it - jump - yeah which is a nice
great way to start right ibly laundering
commas right rent so you can get a kind
of welcome please give me that that
floatiness of that jumps in treatment
right bill threatened one and they've
got this which is this kind of quick jab
that's like his main Punisher smart
combos okay he also does have low stuff
pretty slow startup yeah official swamp
stop there's no way to go Marsha March
March March are the first one was the
first one is one stop right one mark and
he also has ever turned my pockets and
all the time he has yeah conquer bud
yeah pocket money he's got in his pocket
pollen right pocket Paul Hollis bucket
pollen I write it down yeah put it on
the reddit and on the forums that's what
it's called pocket Paul cool so that's
me nothing else really go to it well
those are those are early his good kind
of like combo started makes that options
and say yeah he also is worth pointing
out that is for three in fact we have
extraordinary random play yeah you got
along some of is maybe like one or two
characters they can have random on that
yeah he's done wrong really far along
the longest range yeah again keep seeing
a trend really good range maybe not
always the best start at time yeah but
you can still threaten it to be aware of
the ranges of activity right most
characters are going to be faster than
them very very few is gonna be able to
keep Reaper see absol again that's just
you know that's a good character yeah
I'm gonna learn how he put it that way
let's talk about some special new videos
yeah this is these are some really great
stuff here so some that's a log will
just call on the game you remember log
kick log kicks up yeah right
oh not on your own speed a message is
not really meant to be a projectile
character so that was not this is more
of a complimentary projectile yeah this
is probably closest he has to a
traditional for their time right from it
anything mean yeah yeah yeah a little
bit yeah yeah we actually have one of
those for later yeah yeah but but
normals you don't have one and actually
if you're fullscreen this thing won't
actually heat more actually he again
stay away but he has other things that
can threaten me with that range too so
it's not you know because because
generally when you're at this position
you're going to want to I mean this is
where you're this is where you want to
do yeah yeah like threat spreading
appears man grab shred monkey buddy
right we got the little vines and three
big
yes yes so multiple ranges yes you can
you can hit there's four different
spaces of the screen you can visit so
you've got I think I think it will whip
it's a very very extreme ring but then
these are far version you've got a mid
version and again Buchert there we go
far
yeah I'm in close we can do I'm having
trouble I'm having trouble are you down
for one adventure the wrong button you
got this - there we go first round
section very easy app to do you're not
me
you can also meter burn that for even
more damage sure cane and a lot of it
yeah
and choose which side you're on yeah
which again site switching free right
important area so if they're close to
the corner you can throw them closures
which one yeah like that also we can go
up with it yes yeah and you just do that
by holding up so if you're if you're
threatening someone with the normal and
grounded version you know you can jump
out of those but you can kind of
convince someone to try to jump away
from it right you can you can throw that
out there so this is a lot of arrays yes
like that yeah you have to make the
right decision overnight and make the
right call of we're going to use it yes
jumping is always a little powerful ways
to deal with rattler the swampthing has
a lot of anti options there are high
risk of agates yes one that's right else
we will import a good way from attack of
the tree hmm
one of my favorites so you can great
anti-air gradient across out yes they're
going to try to drop over you hit from
the other side that will hit intercept
and that's another example where if you
think the opponent is going to try to
jump out of your grass you can go for
that and you get it
here you go sir Cabo I did it wrong I'd
to be a I didn't who gave me a good ass
get into that I'm talking about why you
want to why you want to switch sides
with someone all right
this move is a really good example this
right this move will purchase someone's
ability to jump and to gas and does a
little bit of damage over time too so
it's really treacherous but the
trade-off is you can only apply it where
you're walking so you can't jump you
can't - while you're using it so it's
another that Abigail already can't jump
again it'll still be there if you come
for down but you won't be able to
contain right throw back on top of it
jump and then yeah Bhangra exactly right
so yeah your your ability to threaten
others Canaan grass when they're inside
that trap it's way way more green
Abigail's gun Abigail's garden because
every morning yep
yeah then we talk about the body my body
goes up in the throw he shows together
crying whoo yeah he's we found earlier
in the next style valuation I'm not sure
if a lot of people have noticed that if
you do see the weight to combo with him
yeah a lot of people don't notice you're
actually seen characters yeah you end up
as the guy who comes yeah if you
complete the combo which was hard to do
yes and it looked awesome and yeah but
behind the Lord's not a buddy it's him
yeah yeah it is all me
yeah he is a consciousness ex-boyfriend
from any plant and the he terrorized
body yet he was my body I don't need
that thing anymore new ones on the water
you drink right exactly exactly well
yeah we would tend to the water you want
to drink too good so he can he can bring
them out like this and then on me to
burn you can get you go to the spray
here's my love about it you pull scream
please so the animation change the
thinking right yeah right
teleport reading and this is a good move
for people that use for checkout yeah
screen so anyway this is your one move
like you're saying that you can stretch
anywhere in the street right up yet a
real quick to you every month we grow
yep this is a great scooper I love it I
love the little graphic
and the nice thing about is super is the
n2 hits on the ground so it's been in
the stars it's pretty fast so you can
hit them from anywhere yeah
here's the really kind of one of the
moves is his game
yeah it's green thumb right we is a most
versatile moves I say yes and this is
the compliment to the vine grab the vine
grab is great from mid to far range and
then when he gets in this is the bread
and butter up close yep this is your you
can actually have one yeah you cannot
actually hit the vine grab this flow
like the closes around will miss some
other foot for then you have to be the
grab getting you know it is you don't
want to just drop them you could be 9 so
long as you have sweet to them but it
has multiples and we gained it
you can uppercut them get wanted to
Reese and they have them right next view
and those give is damage should do a
deconstructed damage of the leaves him
right next yeah good throw behind yes
yeah again side switching right or for
him if you have a trail you're building
up and you can land that right and look
again you can set him up where they
can't forget jumper down what is though
we can have another option prompting
doesn't have the life leave I don't
think there's any there's nothing he
could have never going to happen well
maybe you can meet a bird can i let's
try that to see what happens take a
little life off of me good idea oh yeah
anything he'll yeah but but my probably
beating it but wait there's more just
then he's giving up his offense it's
true yeah there's no why would you yeah
who would do yeah usually you can do
more damage than you can why would I
choose to do that good question my
supposed to be here but should we try
hitting a button we will try in a button
okay okay we're going to start with the
heel so we'll heal
yeah and then oh man oh wait you can
feel actually you can actually to move
now here's the other thing I actually
work today yes you can do
to that take two bars can you w yes you
can buy a coupla cannot do often yes so
there's a trade-off there yeah we be on
the extra bar you're fitting if you
really knew that life you know you're
not going to be able to do too much
things but you still you know you're so
close to guys so much pressure on
afterward there is so yeah he's got
examine often a lot of options yeah what
do you think see that's Ted swampthing
in it in a nutshell huh yeah trying to
think if there's anything we have it it
is a shadows I don't think so yeah so
lazy diplomatics that is kind of your
your breakdown on how Swamp Thing work
yeah I think we got to the root of its
play style yeah wow we're not done are
we we do want to show though a couple of
his special move you can get from gear
yeah we've had a couple loadout so we
also loaded out a few new you'll need to
show the other one another character now
you're giving it away from later I'm not
going to do them okay alright so here's
another version of Swamp Thing yeah so
what we got by the way art games that
character to get a fantastic job on
modeling a little bit burning year and
my admission that one mistress ethic is
very present so what we just saw is his
hope you can do it standing three and
actually move on and then go in and he
gets all the green box yeah but I know
that controls so much state right more
now has like we had that whole range of
object and normally that move will just
not be portable way and it's kind of a
Gaddafi move this is actual awesome he
actually brings you but it takes one bar
a meter yeah another one which we're is
fun for Swamp Thing is what is it
there we go a very fast typing
projectile yeah we talk in traditional
projectile we can fill that role leader
burn yeah there's some time at Adam yeah
so this would be a great loadout if one
thing is playing to match up where he's
just totally getting yeah if you want to
go here's their lines this is someone he
just he doesn't character that he could
not handle like maybe like Deadshot or
something we use a lot of projectiles
you can actually fire Matt right wait
let's look at the other one too
are you going that one we could do it
this way okay cool what if he really has
trouble getting close is there something
you could do I don't think so
what if he just doesn't feel that it's
character power is gonna be useful not
because he keeps getting knocked away
what can he possibly do well we thought
maybe you've heard this but you haven't
when you have two slots for your
abilities yeah now there are certain
abilities that are very good that will
take up both spots this one takes up
both slots and also replaces have a go
curtain and just totally changes its
character power yeah yeah you want to
get way more aggressive the opposite of
that projectile but yeah I don't want
you to be way I'm gonna be right up on
so in substantial it'll recharge here
for that of course yeah boom very very
powerful iron rattling here very fast
very fast performance right so that is a
couple things a lot of other things
we're not going to show you a really
some for the you know for the game comes
[Music]